vi ricordate quel viaggio bellissimo che
avete fatto quello che raccontate sempre
quello che fa sorridere emozionare ogni
volta che ne parlate e ogni volta che
l'ho riportato alla mente rivivete le
sensazioni più belle i momenti più
intensi i colori suoni i profumi quasi
come foste ancora lì
ecco non è quasi voi siete ancora lì
ogni volta che l'ho riportata la mente è
così incredibilmente vero perché è vero
quanto meno per il vostro cervello
già perché il cervello non distingue tra
realtà e immaginazione
mi spiego meglio se un'esperienza la
vivete sul serio realmente oppure se l'è
immaginato la ricordate per il cervello
non fa differenza è la stessa cosa e di
conseguenza reagisce allo stesso modo
viene da una dimostrazione
guardate qui gara tg4 m.roma c'hai sun
vice e poi e poi con il sec
preghiere wi fi samoa numeri dei house
per becks anas cambiato qualcosa nella
vostra bocca il limone nel video ma la
salivazione vostra se è vero che il
cervello non distingue tra realtà e
immaginazione e abbiamo scoperto che è
vero allora possiamo permetterci di
sbagliare e imparare dai nostri errori
semplicemente simulando evitando così
che gli errori abbiano ripercussioni
reali molti giocatori di basket si
allena attraverso esercizi di
visualizzazione immaginano di tirare e
di fare canestro
vi sto dicendo che stanno allenando per
finta ma indovinate un po la percentuale
di canestri fatti quelli veri
aumenta il cervello non distingue tra
realtà e immaginazione e cosa accade
quando giochiamo
pensateci bene giocare significa fare
qualcosa immaginando di fare
qualcos'altro
il bello del gioco e che esperienziale
fa sì che le persone agiscano e lo fa in
un contesto metaforico lontano da quello
reale cosicché non ci siano giudici e
valutazione ma solo un'espressione non
filtrata dei propri comportamenti
il bello del gioco è che immaginario e
quindi per il cervello reale
ora i bambini passano automaticamente
dal gioco all'apprendimento loro entrano
in questo magico mondo e ne escono
cresciuti con nuove consapevolezze noi
adulti abbiamo bisogno di qualche
passaggio in più
entriamo nel mondo del gioco con lo
viviamo a pieno nei assaporiamo le
sensazioni positive e negative di
soddisfazione o di frustrazione e poi
abbiamo bisogno di fermarci per
riflettere per capire quello che è
successo a guardarci dall'alto così
riusciamo a imparare questo è il
significato dell'apprendimento
ma è inutile parlare a voce a
raccontarvi a voci che cosa significa
un'esperienza bisogna provarla e allora
mettiamo in pratica facciamo un
esercizio pratico tutti insieme
vorrei creare insieme un esercizio che è
il più veloce del mondo vorremmo creare
insieme l'esercizio più veloce del tedax
un gioco che dura undici secondi quindi
vi chiedo cortesemente adesso di
mettervi in coppia e scegliete la
persona la vostra destra la vostra
sinistra e formate una coppia facciamo
un gioco tutti insieme tutti tutti tutti
tutti
scegliete una persona la vostra se non
la trovate la prendete davanti la
prendete indietro
accoppiatevi grazie tutti quanti vediamo
se riusciamo alzare le luci avete creato
la coppia bene tutti quanti anche lassù
bene adesso vi chiedo ho sete già
emozionati ancora dobbiamo cominciare
vi chiedo cortesemente di prendere la
mano destra del nostro nuovo partner in
questo modo in questo modo e di
approcciare i gomiti sul bracciolo della
sedia bene attenzione vi chiedo di
mettere il massimo impegno in questa
sfida perché quello che vi chiedo adesso
in questi undici secondi è di ottenere
il massimo punteggio possibile dove io
ottengo un punto quando la mano del mio
partner tocca la seria e il mio partner
che non punto quando la mia mano tocca
la sedia il massimo impegno in questa
sfida siete pronti 321 via
impegno impegno
ok stop stop start stop grazie fermi
fermi gli undici secondi sono finiti
fifi finiti finiti
altrimenti non è il gioco più veloce del
tedesco signore fermi tutti
allora vediamo se riesco a vederli un
pochino cerchiamo di capire che cosa è
successo
quanti di voi hanno fatto meno di 3
punti alzate le mani così riesco a
vedervi meno di tre punti un uovo o
quanti di voi hanno fatto più di 5 punti
vediamo un pochino più di 5 o più di
dieci più di 10 ok chi è chi si sente
orgoglioso del proprio numero meno
urlate forte forte forte
una mandria di mucche che è successo un
numero forte 25 e com'è possibile
scusatemi 25 e soprattutto come mai
alcuni hanno totalizzato un punto mentre
c'è qualcuno che ne ha fatti 25
le risposte sono due uno ha parato
che poi è quello che normalmente la
gente pensa quando qualcuno che non
risultato migliore del suo oppure ha
rotto uno schema ha ascoltato
l'obiettivo ha ascoltato le regole e ha
deciso di interpretarle al suo favore
l'obiettivo è di ottenere il maggior
punteggio possibile il maggior punteggio
possibile non di battere il partner ma
noi no noi dobbiamo vincere vincere nei
confronti dell'avversario vincere nei
confronti del nemico che poi era il
vostro partner fino a 11 secondi fa ma
ce lo siamo già dimenticati e tutto
questo accade nel nostro cervello
automaticamente è automatico che se io
sono davanti una sfida era devo vincere
è automatico che se metto le mani in
questo modo è braccio di ferro una prova
di forza è così da sempre
viviamo di automatismi prendiamo
decisioni in base alle nostre esperienze
passate
il che la maggior parte delle volte è
vero ed efficace
l'ho già fatto so come funziona
riapplica lo stesso comportamento
ogni volta che trovo una situazione
simile
siamo fatti così biologicamente è un
sistema che il cervello usa per
risparmiare energia
per ottenere lo stesso risultato con un
minore sforzo un sistema quasi sempre
efficace ma non sempre ci sono
situazioni in cui ri applichiamo allo
stesso comportamento
nonostante non funzioni più nonostante
non ci porti più il risultato che
vogliamo comportamento che prima aveva
un senso e adesso non ce l'ha ma che
entrato ormai nel nostro pilota
automatico e quindi non mettiamo ha
neanche più in discussione
e qui che dobbiamo uscire dal gioco e
fermarci fermarci a capire che tavoli
abbiamo sbagliato fermarci a capire che
ci siamo cascati che sciocchi che siamo
stati ciò che è cosa importa era un
gioco non è vita reale e per fortuna
abbiamo perso ma abbiamo perso per finta
ma abbiamo imparato e fidatevi abbiamo
imparato per davvero
se adesso rifacessimo lo stesso gioco
quanti di voi otterrebbero un punteggio
più alto rispetto a quello che avete
ottenuto prima dimostrato avete imparato
a giocare meglio
ora se ritrovasse lo stesso gioco nella
vita reale le stesse dinamiche in una
situazione vera quanti di voi
cambierebbero comportamento dopo aver
visto e fatto questo gioco
bravi avete trasformato un gioco in
apprendimento
un esempio per voi di quanto sia
difficile cambiare un comportamento una
volta che dentro di noi un esperimento
una stanza con dodici scimmie
dentro questa stanza c'è una scala ea
sopra la scala un casco di banane le
scimmie vedono le banane vanno per
prenderlo ma sulle scale sono stati
messi dei sensori collegati a delle
docce fredde
ogni volta che i sensori vengono
calpestati reduce fretta si attivano le
scimmie vanno su docce fredde
ma torniamo indietro si spengono
riprovano docce fredde torniamo indietro
si spengono dopo tre quattro volte le
scimmie decidono di restare
giù e asciutte hanno imparato in base
alle esperienze brave ma è a questo
punto che i sensori vengono disattivati
ora le docce non sono più attivabili di
conseguenza le banane sono raggiungibili
cosa fanno le scimmie niente si stanno
ferme perché perché la loro esperienza
passata condizione i comportamenti
attuali
ma non finisce qui una scimmia viene
sostituita con una nuova fresca vergine
vede le banane va per prendere le banane
le altre cosa fanno
la bloccano fin quando la scimmia non
rinuncia la scimmia rinuncia senza
neanche sapere il motivo per cui non può
prendere le sue banane ancora cambiano
una seconda scimmia
la seconda scimmia vede leva mare va per
prenderle le altre scimmie la bloccano
tutte compresa la prima attenzione
compresa la prima che sta bloccando la
seconda senza neanche sapere il motivo
per cui è come se qualcuno venisse da
voi e di vi dicesse non si può fare voi
ma perché boh non lo so ma so le scimmie
noi umani siamo molto più intelligenti
una per una vengono cambiate tutte le
cime fino a quando nella stanza non si
trovano a dodici scimmie
nessuna delle quali va a prendere le
banane nessuna delle quali sa il motivo
per cui non può
sapete quante scimmia hanno dovuto
sostituire prima che ce ne fosse uno che
dicesse io voglio provare sulla mia
pelle 48 48 scimmie prima che ce ne
fosse una che avesse il coraggio
ora la mia domanda per voi chi di voi
vuole essere la 48esima scimmia
chi di voi ha la forza l'impeto neanche
il coraggio di alzarsi
nonostante le difficoltà nonostante le
resistenze degli alter dire io vado
voglio provare
ecco signori come vedete abbiamo
imparato un po di cose e l'abbiamo fatto
giocando ma se c'è una cosa che vorrei
proteste a caso da questi minuti passati
insieme non è una consapevolezza ma una
domanda la domanda più importante
quando vi trovate davanti un ostacolo
che sembra insormontabile
nel lavoro nella relazione con voi
stessi prima di rinunciare a salire le
scale fate di questa semplice domanda
cosa sto dando per scontato
chissà che non siete voi la 48esima
scena grazie mille